I want to talk a little bit more about
Steve Ducey Steve Ducey is one of the
three hosts of The Fox News Morning Show
Fox and Friends alongside alongside
Ainsley Earhart and Brian kilmead and
Steve Ducey over the last couple of
weeks has had a few sort of off-script
sane moments where he will interject
some reality into the propaganda that is
Fox and Friends and his co-hosts don't
really seem to like it earlier this week
I played for you a clip of Steve Ducey
trying to explain to his co-host hey you
know there is this thing called the the
crime fraud exception in the law and if
you understand it you understand a lot
of what's going on with these 34 felony
counts against Donald Trump and his his
co-host did not like it Steve Ducey went
off script again when he pointed out
Trump really shouldn't be talking about
the judge's family and the prosecutor or
the judge on social media it's really
not appropriate to be doing that and
Brian kilomet again just kind of rolls
his eyes and says oh trump it was a
really great speech that Trump gave if
something is up with Steve Ducey and he
seems to be trying God bless him uh take
a look at this and one of the last speak
and one of the point before we go uh one
of the last things that Lucas reported
on this morning is prosecutors yesterday
during the indictment uh brought up to
uh Trump and his team
the threatening post that Donald Trump
made he posted on true social uh there
would be death and destruction would
follow if uh he were charged and the
judge uh warned him and his attorneys
make sure that doesn't happen six hours
later at Mar-A-Lago the judge was
attacked the judge's wife and the
judge's daughter the judge's daughter
wound up on true social and a bunch of
social media sites yesterday because she
works for a consulting firm that did
work for Hunter rather Hunter Biden or
the Biden Harris he's trying he's
struggling with a cough he's struggling
to read his notes he's mixing up names
but he's trying he's saying Trump was
told don't go after yeah don't don't do
these inflammatory posts and then he's
attacking the judge the judge's family
and the prosecutor and and Brian
Kilmeade is not pleased with this uh
campaign if you go on their website we
were scrolling through it yesterday they
they represent a lot of Democrats a lot
of Progressive Democrats
very bad look to attack the family he
said these he just mentioned that they
are attack Alvin Braggs attacking him
his wife posted something negative about
him and the daughter works for Democrats
so see Brian Kilmeade says it's fine oh
there seems to be an agenda he didn't
say attack the family he mentioned them
in a speech I thought his speech was
tight last night
we all watched that speech live it was a
tight speech Trump rambled incoherently
about his normal list of Grievances and
seemed to be focused rather than on the
crimes that he has been formally accused
of on his other potential crimes for
which he's not yet been accused and then
abruptly wrapped it up by saying make
America great again even though the
country's under a dark cloud not exactly
a tight speech I believe how tidy was to
the problem a lot of support it seems
like boom boom boom this is what I'm
doing this we're going here's the
problem with our country gotta run and I
like that he did it in Florida he's like
I'm getting the heck out of New York
yeah Yep they're sitting in New York by
the way as they say the good thing he
got the hell out of here this place
sucks so listen I don't I don't know
what's going on with Steve Ducey it
really is I'm not speculating that oh he
has seen the light or he hasn't but he's
pretending because of this reason or
that reason or someone's in his ear I
don't have any speculation as to what's
going on what I can tell you is what I
see
three or four times over the last
several weeks and twice this week Steve
Ducey has tried to introduce some
reality some cogent analysis of the real
world
to his co-hosts and they just basically
steamroll right over it and say
everything's fine Trump's speech was
tight he wasn't really threatening he
was just mentioning oh all these people
who are against me are biased and on and
on there might be some story here you'll
remember with Shepard Smith at Fox News
you started to see little bits and
pieces of this inkling that something
was not there was trouble in Paradise so
to speak and next thing you knew Shep
was gone from Fox News uh I don't know
what's up with Steve Ducey his son also
works Peter Ducey for Fox News but it is
certainly interesting to see